[Musik]
warum hörte auf zu klatschen und mein
name ist luca meine damen und herren und
ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet herzlich willkommen hier zu
einer weiteren folge
luca bei dieser atemberaubenden serie
auf meinem kanal befinde ich mich auf
einer video plattform namens oracle und
werde mit euch meinen zuschauern video
chatten heute wird das ganze allerdings
nicht so ablaufen dass sich einfach mit
den leuten reden werde und mal schauen
wer da was so passiert sondern ich werde
mich zuerst verstecken und dann mit
dieser maske bei meinem gesicht
hochkommen und die leute quasi
erschrecken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lotte
hallo was geht hast du dich erschrocken
ich wollte heute mit der maske
erschrecken aber irgendwie hat das sie
erst einmal nicht funktioniert
einigen fotos bitte schön
ja
die hat komme ich auf diesen bisschen
durcheinander hat kommunion da ist mal
durcheinander jannis was geht bei dir
gerade was machst du so hast du gewonnen
ja ich hab noch nie gewonnen
dass es dir leid tut ja noch den grüßen
ja klar natürlich laser luca auf
instagram on ice
danke an die schöne grüße für mich hey
hallo hallo hallo
na habt ihr euch erschrocken man ich
wollte leute erschreckt mit dieser maske
aber das funktioniert nicht
erschreckte mich gerade ja was soll ich
mal in den handstand machen
ich werde mich war matura in seinem
früheren leben halt mal was geht so
gerade bei dir was machst du so wieso
musst du den garten gehen bis zu 100
muss den garten saubermachen laub fällt
eigentlich eher im herbst runter nicht
im frühjahr
was ich erschrocken von mir und weniger
das erste mal dass ich jemand einen witz
bisschen erschrocken hat wie gerade in
der schule nach hause gekommen
cool schule habe ich gehasst früher ist
so gut in der schule oder er so komplett
scheiße befriedigend ist fast gut und
gutes fast sehr gut schreibt mir alle in
die kommentare herzlichen glückwunsch
nadine da drei plätze der deutsche aber
all das ist hammer krass kam auch aus
viele fällt was wo wohnst du kika de ki
ka ist ein fernsehsender
ki.ka der kinderkanal 2000 jahre später
sieht ja ich habe tiger verstanden ich
dachte an diese fernseh sender ja ich
wohne im fernsehsender hast du dich
erschrocken muss ich es doch ich kann
auch furchteinflößend sein was geht so
bei dir was machst du gerade
schule ist ein wundervoller ort wo auf
welche schule gehst du ärgerst die cafés
halter die ganze schule kommt einfach
meine videos glaube das hat heute so für
fächer englisch musik kann schon mal was
vorsingen hast du dich erschrocken
formiert ja auch
ja das war überhaupt nicht ironisch
glaube ich das geht so bei dir wie heißt
du scheiß lgln kürbis ein gramm
aber du bist nicht die königin von
england doch woran lag's
ja doof ja klar ruft eine mutter an
hallo hallo mutter von elite mir geht's
super wg ziehen
ja schön
immer schön botschafter schauen
der rakete
aber mit einer rakete zum mond fliegen
natürlich kann ich durchgehend im wasser
schön
guter grund erste die bahnen fisch oder
ein vogel
auch ein fisch wärst du lieber ein fisch
oder kong crafter krank macht das was
ist hier auch von wieder meine damen und
herren ich hatte mal wieder bock auf
mehr geht und ich hatte mir gedacht
kommen bevor ich ganz normal mit den
leuten reden mache ich einfach eine
maske auf meine fresse damit ich ein
bisschen schöner aussehen und die leute
damit der strecke wenn euch das video
gefallen hat freuen und dann erst mal
leid das schaffen wir 60.000 likes das
ist eine riesige summe aber wenn ihr
bock hat dass diese serie wieder
wöchentlich kommt packt diese summe das
wäre echt de blic schreibt mir doch mal
unten in die kommentare freunde wärt ihr
lieber ein vogel oder wird die lieber
ein fisch ich weiß nicht warum ich weiß
nicht warum sie das gefragt habe aber
schreibt mir das mal und sonst würde ich
jetzt eigentlich noch sagen dass wasser
ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auch die glocken klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]